hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute möchte ich noch mal
ein rezept mit rhabarber machen und zwar
gibt es einen rhabarberkuchen mit
vanillecreme und streuseln denn ich
wurde nach meinem letzten rhabarber
rezept also noch diesem rabbi dekoren
gefragt was könnte man den stadtplatz
statt zum abc maße nehmen und ich hab
mir gedacht kommen wir nehmen einfach
bissle streusel aber machen daneben noch
eine leckere vanille creme kräutern
schmeckt nämlich der kuchen nicht so
trocken sondern ist trotzdem schön
saftig und vor allem hat man diese
elektro vanillecreme mit dabei wir haben
jetzt ein paar zutaten also es geht auf
den ersten blick viel aus insgesamt drei
schichten ein rührteig eine quarkcreme
rhabarber und dann die streusel aber es
ist viel also im prinzip sind viele
grundzutaten und daneben noch der
rhabarber
also ich zeige euch jetzt mal ich hab
jetzt hier 600 kamera war dann brauche
ich für die quarkcreme 125 gramm quark
dass ich jetzt ein magerquark 150 gramm
sahne 35 km speisestärke 35 gramm zucker
etwas vanille exakt und eine bio limite
davon brauche ich saft und etwas schale
dann brauche ich für den rührteig 100
gramm weiche butter 100 gramm zucker 225
gramm nähe und einen halben teelöffel
backpulver und endet prise salz da kommt
auf vinyl extrakt rein und dann habe ich
dann die streusel und dafür stehen wir
schon die drei zutaten
ich habe jetzt hier kalte butter
insgesamt sind es jetzt 75 gramm
ich habe 65 gramm zucker und 100 ml und
für den rhabarber brauch ich gleich ein
vorbild
außer puste wie so oft bis auf den
rhabarber ist eigentlich alles so genau
es auf das cover hat man immer alles
muss den rabatt scheele grad so wisse
man kann übrigens auch abba schale mit
essen muss muss länger dann aber da ich
halt viel mehr von dieser oxalsäure drin
als jetzt im rhabarber ihnen selbst
schon deswegen schädigt es halt immer
das machen sondern so säuerlich ja vor
allem deshalb auf den zähnen total
unangenehm und ich glaube oxalsäure in
hoher dosis auch nicht gesund deswegen
immer die schade lieber weg
könnte es sein dass du eine schürze
vergessen wie ich habe absichtlich nicht
an weil ich auf holz eine salatsauce
okay aber ich sehe im bau ja und ich
sehe deine auch und schwanger ja ich bin
auch hinter der kamera ich bin die regie
und schwanger da verbrauch zeigt
außerdem schon ein paar monate direkt
und 100 wieder abtrainieren soll ich das
mit der männer ist nicht mit schwacher
dann ist ja seit sechs monaten dauert
seit sechs jahren dauer schreiber oder
und jetzt wird der rhabarber in kleine
stückchen geschnitten ich halte nicht
weil ich hab so ganz dicke strenge und
schneidet mir die dann einfach kleinen
runter seine hose klackert ich meine ich
habe vor so ein blind ton im ohr
ja ich hab selber heute ankommen das
regal nach 30 versuchen das zu wackeln
wird gehe ich hier noch ein bisschen zu
betreiben ist natürlich optional weil es
kein film mag lässt halt weg aber ich
finds zentrums einig marokko für immer
mit reiben und ich gebe da jetzt noch so
eins ist zwei esslöffel zucker mit rein
und das lassen jetzt einmal kurz hier an
der seite stehen dann kann das nämlich
schön durchziehen klicks starte ich
einfach mit dem rührteig das mache ich
jetzt hier in der küchenmaschine können
aber natürlich auch ein handrührgerät
und ich mache es jetzt gleich alles in
der gleichen schüssel das heißt wir
brauchen hier nur eine schüssel und
einzel zwei elemente da gebe ich jetzt
die weiche butter rein und da ist auch
wichtig dass jetzt alle zutaten
zimmerwand zumindest beim rührteig da
kommt der zucker mit dazu wie steinbrück
allgemein so das ist alles die gleiche
temperatur haben nicht damit die mutter
annett gerät dann die preise fallen
und gleich nochmal lettern vergesse ich
dass jetzt gleich nicht weil es keinen
vanille extrakt abnimmt einfach bisserl
vanillezucker wobei das halt intensiver
schmeckt und echte vanille und es lasse
ich jetzt cremig rühren so etwa 23
minuten und dann kommen erst die eier
betreiben
jetzt kommt bei mir die eier mit seinen
einzug
jetzt fahre ich einfach den halben
teelöffel backpulver mit dem mehl
einfach damit es nicht verklumpt und
sich schön verteilen kann gibt es auch
mit zu der eier butter masse und lass es
nur noch ganz kurz verrühren und am
besten bei niedrigster stufe
und die zeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
über brücken und meine backform
einfetten als ich habe 10 24 cm backform
die fertig mit etwas back trance vol 1
so tragisch auch fertig ihr könnt das
ganze auch im blech backen also hab ich
das auch schon gemacht dann aber mit der
doppelten menge also wenn ihr die
doppelte menge nimmt durch das perfekt
für blechkuchen und es ist halt auch und
kuchen der geht er einfach man braucht
nicht viele zutaten und geschäfte viele
menschen auch gedacht wieder den grad
der einstreichen
kratz die schüsse jetzt richtig gut aus
denn ich will ja auch gleich die cvag
rente machen ohne jetzt die schüssel
vorher aus rasche zu müssen
dann einfach da drin verstreichen mal
kurz die silikon matte damit ich mir
nicht den herd verkratzen
wobei es bei der demo nicht schlimm wäre
oder verletzte hut nehmen sie dennoch
austausch immer noch immer genauso wie
die zeit backöfen
das war man richtig aufflog wurden zwei
burschen und der und die die
induktionsplatte und jetzt werde ich
ihnen derzeit schon mal die quarkmasse
zu bereiten
übrigens waren das 1925 sondern 250 also
eine halbe große packung oder halten
ganz kleines bild vertan
und das geht jetzt ganz einfach einen
wird die zutaten alle reihen geben
unter einem schneebesen verrühren ich
habe jetzt drin quark sahne stärke etwas
vanille zucker und gleich hole ich mir
noch meine reise und dann kann ich
nämlich noch die limetten schon abreisen
unser nacht direkt die limetten
limettensaft reingeben dann nehme ich
jetzt aber nur die halbe menge
millimeter also sobald glatt gerührt ist
das hier fertig perfekt und das
streichen wir jetzt über diesen rührteig
und wir brauchen da jetzt auch keine zum
binden weil ich habe jetzt da schon
speisestärke trennen als jetzt bei
seiner käsekuchen maße zum beispiel
braucht man ja auch immer ein bisserl
damit es bindet die schüssel wird
ziemlich schwer meinte schüssel ist
durch bei der edelstahl schüsse natur
weiter absetzen
ja aber und da braucht jetzt keiner zu
das jetzt auch schön glatt streichen
und da kommt jetzt direkt darauf aber
mit drauf
und jetzt immer schon gleich fertig
stellen jetzt fehlen auch die streusel
und dafür gebe ich jetzt auf mehr
eine prise salz und die butter in die
schüssel wunsch dass verknetet er kurz
mit flacherer oder einfach mit den
händen also das geht auch gutes in der
streusel wenn er sowieso krümelig
und dann könnte die streusel rausnehmen
und dass man jetzt auch mit der hände
so sparen wir uns noch weg zurück kennen
sie einfach darüber geben also das ist
echt richtig leichter und einfacher
kuchen denen wirklich jeder hinbekommen
sollte weil im prinzip beim rührteig
kann relativ wenig schief geben solange
die zutaten alle zimmer waren sind
gerinnt da auch keine butter wobei es
auch nicht schlimm ist wenn sie gerät
ist einfach bisschen länger weiter
rühren und dann ist es auch schon wieder
behoben
von daher ist es relativ einfach
der kuchen darf jetzt im ofen bei 170
grad ober und unterhitze für ungefähr 40
minuten backen
weil ich unten der teig schön durch die
quarkcreme wird fest und die streusel
werden schön knusprig danach muss ich in
zwei stunden abkühlen lassen und dann
zeige ich euch das endergebnis
ich habe den kuren jetzt abkühlen lassen
zwei stunden einfach bei raumtemperatur
ihr könnt ihn aber zum beispiel auch
gerne einfach über nacht in den
kühlschrank stellen
da müsste ihm vorher nur abdecken das
erhaltet trocknet und vor allem hat so
nach kühlschrank richtig mag das so wenn
man so eine sache ob im kühlschrank
stehen hat jetzt nehme ich ihn mit
seiner tortenplatte runter das ist
übrigens die trotte platz die dem rad
mal in den geschirrspüler gestellt hat
fuchs habe ich heute ganz kuchen
mitgenommen also der stoffe bisserl
lauwarm hätte noch ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen müssen dann wären wir das jetzt
hier an und abgefahren war abgebrochen
und wer möchte kann ihn jetzt mit
puderzucker noch bestäuber als ich
nämlich wieder süßen schnee der schmilzt
ja dann nicht auf der oberfläche und
bleibt einfach schön drauf liegen
daher sei wieder leer
und dann lässt sich besser schneiden
wenn er wirklich kalt ist und dann
schmeckt er auch besser weil dann diese
quarkcreme schon kalt ist schmeckt dann
ähnlich wie so ein pudding
und ich denke das sieht man jetzt hier
ganz gut diese schicht mit dem quad und
dann diese schicht durch diesen durch
die rubber stücke und obendrauf daneben
die leckeren sträußen und so könnte den
kuchen dann einfach servieren ganz gut
dazu würde es noch geschlagene sahne
passen weil zum streuselkuchen finde ich
kann man gut mit sunedison könnte auch
im prinzip eine kugel eis zu legen
das ist jedem selber überlassen mein
rezept gibt es du nachlesen auf sallys -
blog.de und ich würde mich freuen wenn
ihr den kuchen nach macht und bis dann
ein foto schickt auf facebook
und ich würde sagen wir sehen uns
einfach beim nächsten mal wieder und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim nach
fakten des amtes
diese mache ich rechts oben in
einfachzählung
immer wenn du einfach einfach sagt dann
dann zählt er mit
da stand alles wenn mir das video wir
arbeiten kommt oben einfach zellstoff
netz doch lustig wie so etwas wie die
bar ein rascher bearbeitet
also folgt vorstellen setzte sich doch
bald schon bearbeitet jetzt natürlich
vollpfosten hast du wenig dass die leute
die schüler mit geräten und einem
anderen wort vollpfosten ende